[Music]
this is where it happens with a smile
a skillful touch
I thought the look the morning rush an
evening stroll out in the cold but
always warm we are the front line here
us see how we work together
[Music]
with Chromebooks in our hands
we'll be faster
more connected
[Music]
keep going the distance
[Music]
because we are the frontline hi everyone
thanks for joining us this afternoon
to learn how to turn your frontline
workers into cloud workers with with
Chrome Enterprise you'd be amazed at how
long it took Leslie to train me how to
do that sequence oh I just did it took a
bit it's getting late in the day but
thanks again for taking the time a name
is Mike doused I head up our Chrome
Enterprise go-to-market team and I have
the privilege to kick things off today
and we'll walk you through some research
that we've done around this frontline
worker segments and some great
understandings and how the cloud can
help here as well as Chrome enterprise
and then walk you through some use cases
with companies that we've worked with to
date and then I'll hand things over to
Robby who leads up IT for stitch fix a
company that hopefully most of you have
all heard and utilized and he'll take
you through real-life examples that that
he's encountered with his front line
workers and chrome enterprise hopefully
we'll have time for questions we got
about 45 minutes if you haven't been to
any sessions and utilized the dory this
is a capability you can see the
instructions here that if you have some
thoughts as we go through the content
and you want to submit a question feel
free to do that and then if we have time
at the end we'll utilize this will also
take live questions here as well so
before we dive into the the frontline
worker first want to talk a little bit
about the cloud worker this is a
narrative we kicked off actually this
time last year and it was a bunch of
research we did across 1,400 ID
decision-makers and users with Forrester
it was a really interesting research
that really at the end of the day to sum
it up it it it said everyone in their
day-to-day lives their personal lives is
operating in the cloud they leverage
content they leverage applications no
matter what location in their personal
lives whether it's Netflix and Spotify
whether it's getting to work using
Google Maps with uber and lyft they're
used to having information applications
that their fingertips to make their day
truly efficient and they
taking that same expectation into
enterprises and handed that problem so
to speak to too many of you in the room
here today and but what was interesting
about the research at the time is last
year basically it found that about
quarter of the folks within any
organizations small medium or large our
cloud workers they're ready they're
ready to adopt the cloud their
expectations are there and the
excitement and the opportunities there
and it's only grown as more workloads
move to the cloud as as the SAS sort of
steam train continues to triple
year-on-year growth this is becoming
more and more reality and and really
it's something that we see as a
tremendous opportunity for this
frontline worker segment at the end of
the day I think in the old world you
know how you worked or what your job
category was sort of determined what you
needed on a day-to-day basis and the
reality is now it's not really where you
work but how you work and what you need
to do on a day to day basis and anyone
can fundamentally be a cloud worker
today whether they traditionally are an
information worker whether they're out
in the field in the back office
they can be a cloud worker but what's
interesting is that the segment that
often gets forgotten and I'll walk
through this a little bit is this
frontline worker in terms of taking the
cloud to them so that they can be more
effective and efficient in driving the
organization's strategy who are these
cloud who are these frontline workers
interestingly enough it's about 80
percent of the workforce these are these
desolace workers that aren't like some
of us sort of chained to a desk their
cashiers their call center agents
their project managers that could be on
construction sites their nurses their
EMTs they're out there in the field
working hand in hand selling products
supporting products and services and are
very much the face and a backbone of any
company or most companies that are out
there today
they directly impact the CX to the
customer experience and in this customer
experience has huge top line and bottom
line impact
as you can see here from the Gartner
study 90% of companies compete primarily
based on customer experience and you can
see the Harvard Business Review sort of
backs that up with you know people that
have had a positive past purchased will
spend one hundred forty percent more on
their next one and I think we can all
relate to that you know I way way way
back when when I was in the restaurant
business and was a frontline you know
bartender or waiter what-have-you or
worked in the hotel business
I had managers that always said you know
if you if a customer has a bad
experience they're probably gonna tell
five to ten more people than they would
if they had a good one so this has both
a positive and negative impact and and
executives and companies are seeing this
in measuring the performance of this
however the same token these same
leaders feel like you know but you know
the investment isn't there in these
frontline workers not giving them the
tools they need to really elevate and
and meet the needs of this customer
experience and you can see it here in
terms of the frontline worker managers
themselves and those actual workers 75%
of them feel like they don't have
consistent communication to really carry
the message both from a compliance
standpoint and a strategy standpoint to
their customers to do their day-to-day
job so it's a huge you know missed
opportunity in many ways and again it's
interestingly not validated by both the
leaders within these organizations as
well as the frontline worker managers
and their in their users
we actually did some surveying ourselves
to sort of test this out as well it
asked both information workers and
frontline workers what kind of effect
technology has had in terms of a
positive effect over the last past
year's past five years sorry information
workers 70 percent felt like it had a
positive impact frontline workers one
out of every two said it had a positive
impact so think about that for a minute
there's been a lot of positive technical
changes in the marketplace but still
only one out of every two frontline
workers actually feel like it helped
their experience to do their job better
right so huge missed opportunity here
but what does it all mean what does it
result in why should you care at the end
of the day is that you know if you have
disengagement here and you can see here
you know if you have pessimism within
this frontline worker base and you can
see the statistics here back in 2016
there's a 65% turnover rate within these
frontline workers and underneath this is
if you take you know a semi average
hourly employee they make $30,000 a year
research shows that about 20 to 25
percent of that salary is needed to hire
the next employee so you can see how you
get to this hundreds of billions of
dollars of lost productivity and revenue
to companies every year it's it's pretty
staggering and amazing it's not all bad
news
there's some good news here and the good
news here is you know we really think
and we have some proof both from outside
research as well as experiences with
ourselves and customers like stitch fix
that the cloud can help solve this right
it can really help elevate these
frontline workers in terms of their
employee experience they're ready they
like all of us and some of them may be
in the room are using the cloud in their
day to day personal lives so their usage
in their expectation level is there and
if they are more engaged and they are
having a more positive experience that's
going to pass on to the customer
experience and have that positive
positive impact on top of that the cloud
can really deliver a higher level of
security and we've seen that in Chrome
enterprise and we'll talk a little bit
about that and ideally and we've seen
this as well as can deliver you a more
productive solution at a lower cost so
all these elements are really the
positive light that we want to talk a
little bit about in terms of the
opportunity that you have with your
frontline worker segment for chrome
antor prize for those of you they're not
aware of it this really encompasses
Chrome browser Chrome OS and Chromebooks
as well as the management capabilities
that come with this offering you can see
here on on the left side of the slide
you know you have sort of what it brings
to the business so folks that are here
in the room managing endpoints or end
users as well as on the right what
benefits that can bring to the users
and I'll walk through each aspect to
this as we go through these these slides
here
first of all security I think you know
those who have been on sort of the
chrome journey hopefully you know at
this point that security is really
paramount and and probably the first key
pillar to any feature or device or
functionality that we roll out with
chrome and it really is the highest bar
both from browser OS to any Chrome
device that's out there and we have
multi layers of security and we could
definitely take you through reviews but
I think what we can say confidently is
that most folks that go through this and
look at it from a security standpoint
are pretty well pleased we've put a lot
of work into sort of isolating certain
you know encrypted profiles management
of applications and the beauty of chrome
is that it does update every six weeks
so and in most all those updates have
security capabilities that are added and
those are things that you can either
take advantage of or manage and roll
those out as time as needed right but
security is definitely a really high bar
and a true differentiator when it comes
to chrome Enterprise from a licensing
standpoint what you get with the license
is a number of things but just to point
out a couple here is you get really
policy management across your users and
your endpoints so two hundred-plus of
them think of it as if you have a
segment of users so a set of frontline
workers that are mobile workers and you
have an application or set of
applications that you want them to have
access to you can push those to those
users you can also blacklist certain
applications so they don't have access
to those gives you kind of a full
breadth of user management in that
regard
you also have device management so that
if you know a device disappears or gets
lost you can essentially disable that
device so it is non operable and and you
know causes no harm to your environment
so it gives you the full breadth and
we're constantly updating those policies
we've also the product teams done a
phenomenal job working with a set of our
partners that are in this EMM space to
open up our api's so that you can
leverage if you've made investment in
any of these providers you can have that
single pane of glass and still manage
your devices like you may manage a
mobile device or any other device you
have in your fleet so we're trying to
really help bridge the gap between what
you've purchased in the past as well as
sort of enabling that for the future and
then obviously you get a lot of the
common enterprise 24 by 7 support that
you would get with any enterprise
offering savings is a big piece of this
and yeah a couple slides here to talk
through that Google is a great example
we still are a company that allows
ultimate flexibility in terms of what
types of operating system and devices
you you can utilize we're seeing
obviously a high growth in in chrome
being a huge segment of that but you can
see some of the comparables here and I
think it's it's really something that a
lot of times customers don't really
fathom until they've experienced it is
that one the set up of the device can be
far simpler so you can see here it's
approximately 33 minutes to set up a
chrome device and close to
two-and-a-half hours for a comparable
device with the other platforms and this
is coming from our IT support teams at
Google that are supporting tens of
thousands of these once you have a
device out there in the field then
there's the support of that device and
we measure that you know ticket per
thousand tickets that are out there and
it's about 19 tickets per thousand our
chrome tickets and almost a hundred for
a comparable Windows Device so we are a
great testament of the fact that both
the setup and the support of these
devices is far lower than we're more
finding in our environment and we
continue to sort of pull this and happy
to share some of these statistics with
you if it'll help in your engagements
this multi user experience again is
something that sometimes candidly we we
struggle to explain to companies and the
uniqueness of it and often times when
they start to deploy chrome sort of the
light bulb goes off but in essence you
can have as many encrypted cloud
profiles running on these devices so
much like if you're familiar with
Education and Chromebooks and you know
60 plus percent market share in the u.s.
here alone is a big part of that value
proposition was kids
could jump into a classroom pull a
Chromebook off the shelf and use that in
a secure way we've taken that to the
enterprise as well so that amongst your
frontline workers many of them may have
multiple shifts throughout you know the
course of a day and so you can have
those same set of devices be used by a
large magnitude of frontline workers by
the way for a bunch of different use
cases so it securely knows who you are
what applications you have access to you
can you then can set it so that it it
wipes automatically on logout or you can
set it to timeout and and and wipe those
devices so all the security components
are there the next frontline worker
comes in can pull that Chromebook off
the shelf and do what they need this is
a piece that when I talk to any CIOs
right on down to the IT folks that are
managing devices really believe this is
unparalleled like the the slide says in
terms of a differentiated capability
it's something that allows you quite
frankly to deploy less devices out in
the field but serve more users this
again is is sort of speaks a bit to the
savings here Dave over schnooks a
grocery chain and the Midwest has been
using Chromebooks and you can see here
you know quite openly as saving $1,250
per year on device costs and you can see
on the left-hand side again it starts a
bit with the hardware and software an
initial investment there's a bit here in
terms of employee productivity so you
know being able to to be productive on a
day to day basis as a component of it
but I think again the 75% improvement in
terms of IT productivity and savings on
what IT is used to is really a big
proponent and I often say you know when
i chat with with cxos that are out there
they always have more projects than
people so if you can save them time on
this there's plenty of projects for them
to pick up outside of managing devices
and endpoints and chrome can give you
that capability I think from a user
standpoint a lot of these things we've
been talking about for years but I think
are good reminders the fact that a
Chromebook can can boot up in about six
seconds is still pretty amazing a lot of
us has been living in that world so we
forget the old world of
the device on grab a cup of coffee come
back and be productive this again is
something that is is is definitely a
differentiator and continues to be a big
piece of the value proposition the
cloud-based profiles is something I
mentioned before the saved ID time and
then basically you know quick access to
what you need to do on a day to day
basis and we're always trying to
incorporate things around ml in the
background with our partners and with
our employees to help make it a more
productive experience on a device and
something that's unique to allow them to
do what they need to do on a day to day
basis in terms of form factors we've
made a lot of progress here I think when
I started about six seven years ago we
had one om and one device that we were
we were deploying across the globe now
you can you can see that every major om
has a set of devices in the marketplace
I think what's pretty exciting too is
that it runs the gamut in terms of form
factor from tablet to convertible to
desktop to clamshell and and really
what's great about it when you think
about your segments within your
workforce is everything from lower end
to medium to really premium devices and
I think we're really excited for the
future here because I think we're gonna
continue to build out that portfolio
with our OEM partners so it gives you
sort of the breadth and depth you need
to meet the needs of not just your
frontline workers but in the in the
future more and more your information
workers as well G suite is something
here that you know we definitely wanted
to mention I think many of our chrome
customers started as G suite customers
which makes a lot of sense they've
evolved and are using the cloud for
their their main collaboration
applications and have really bought in
and invested there and so chrome is a is
a is a logical fit and we continue to
work across our teams to figure out ways
to bring a unique value in this the same
time we have many many customers that
that deploy Chrome browser then Chrome
OS and then start to think about what
applications they could be running in
the cloud so it does go both ways and I
think what we really try to do is bring
the best of both worlds here and a lot
of times its customers who are thinking
about this but I think what we
definitely have
as those of you that have invested in G
Suite and have not deployed Chromebooks
what it will do is you will get more out
of your investment because you're really
pushing people to be cloud enabled and
it allow you to you know get better
value out of those investments you've
made in the cloud a couple of examples
before I turn things over to Robbie that
I think bring this a bit to life
Middlesex Hospital health care is one of
our target verticals has deployed
Chromebooks in a number of use cases I
won't go through all elements of the
slide but in essence they're deploying
it for many use cases as an example
nurses that need ongoing compliance and
HR training that are coming in multiple
times of the day and multiple shifts can
leverage Chromebooks either one-to-one
or in a shared environment to get that
training they're using it for EMTs so
think about use cases where every second
matters same type of thing for EMTs to
get the training they need but also to
support their day-to-day business when
they're out there working with patients
and at the end of the day again it goes
back to that customer experiences it's
all about how can the patient experience
be improved and if chrome devices can
help from a Productivity standpoint so
they can spend more time with their
patients it's a win-win and they're
seeing that in spades and are always
looking for more use cases to to add
chrome to her via is is a utility
company in Ireland and so you can
imagine the use cases here in terms of
highly distributed workforce across the
country supporting a bunch of different
frontline workers that are out in the
field and you know chrome has enabled
them both from a grab-and-go which
hopefully if you haven't seen it here at
the conference there's a series of
grab-and-go booths where you can
essentially think of it as loaner
devices they're leveraging these for
folks that may have lost it of ice or
just need a device for a couple of hours
to do their timekeeping or HR
capabilities or any other applications
they need to access as well as what they
need out in the field
so again chrome is a great enabler here
for applications that that are not cloud
enabled they're also leveraging VDI so
we've made a lot of efforts over the
to make sure if you don't have those
those applications in the cloud yet or
maybe they're not Android applications
because those are compatible with Chrome
as well VDI is a bridge that'll help you
get there as well a couple more Mercado
Libre latin america company in mexico
actually that's leveraging Chromebooks
for contact centers right so I think we
really think of you know contact centers
is a great frontline worker segment
we're seeing more and more like Mercado
where this is a outsource function one
that has a lot of remote requirements
and oftentimes IT does not have the
bandwidth to support these you know
growing customer service and contact
agents and I think Mercado is a great
case of where they've now have contact
center agents that again can be up and
running within six to ten seconds you
can really meet the needs of their
customer so in essence they're happier
so their customers are happier so grande
a great use case it is one where we have
a number of companies that are utilizing
it you know this and it's it's sort of
come to our attention many of them were
doing it without us even knowing they
just they just stumbled on the use case
and I think as more and more contact
center applications move to the cloud
this is an outstanding use case to start
with in any organization and then the
last one before I turn things over is
Charles Schwab they made a customer a
couple years now you know it is a
financial services company of course but
it's it's think of it as as very much a
retail frontline worker use case in that
they've deployed Chromebooks across all
of their branches and really like many
of these wealth management companies
their goal is to really empower their
customers to utilize the investment they
made in online applications both for
financial planning portfolio planning
and the like and so they've deployed
chrome devices so that anyone who comes
in to the branch can either work with a
representative on their wealth planning
but ideally that representative turns a
Chromebook around and says help yourself
here this is where you log in this is
how you can utilize that so they think
it can become much more self-sufficient
so hopefully you can think of many used
within your organization that are
similar to that which have that element
of helping from a customer satisfaction
standpoint but also helping them serve
themselves by utilizing their device as
well so those are a few use cases again
I just touched on sort of the high level
pieces obviously we'll take some
questions here at the end but I think
I'm really excited to bring Ravi up here
who can speak a little bit in depth on
what they're doing it's terrific so if
you could please give them a warm
welcome thank you thank you Mike
oh good afternoon everyone I'm Robin
Durham the head of IT at stitch fix I've
been with stitch fix a little over three
and half years and we are a I would say
a cloud native company that's that kind
of puts it in a very positive situation
when you start looking at chrome devices
so our VR app G suite customer but the
aura specific use case here is in our
warehouse operations I think for us at
stitch fix we fulfill products so how
many of you here in the audience are
customers of stitch fix that heard of
switch fix raise of hands the rest of
you sign up so is so part of just to
give you a little bit of a snippet of
how the stitch fix the business model
works is that as you complete your
profile we have be a product that's
already in our warehouse is that we
algorithm Italy pick and then present it
to a remote stylist stylist takes that
system recommendations algorithm
recommendations and then picks the best
product suitable for you and then that
at that point is where the handoff
happens to our warehouse associates in
our warehouses we have five warehouses
currently at in in stitch that we
fulfill product in the US we are
expanding into UK in the this calendar
year I think the and we are we started
with the Women's Business Star launch
demands and now we are doing kids so I
have no excuse not to sign up so ad so
the the touch point for from a from a
warehouse associates standpoint it is
not so much about the chrome the G suite
applications it's more the application
that we built in-house for our product
fulfill
so think of it as like a product like
when you pick a product in a we're in
the warehouse so that is the use case
that we're using so we have as I said we
have five different warehouses we have
workers that are that sign in to that
they sign in to the applications that
they need to interact with I throw
barcode scanner so what you can see in
this image is the Chrome device attached
to a symbol barcode scanner and attached
to a cart so the cart is where we pick
the product so we authenticate through
their badge to put them into the profile
that they need to be and then from there
they have the set of applications that
they're authorized to access so all our
applications that we use through the
Chrome device are Nate browser native
app browser application process based
applications there's no client involved
as far as chrome made a lot of sense to
put that on the on the front line so for
us it is most it not only the the
cost-effectiveness I think the ability
to have those applications easily
accessible so once you're authenticated
you know the apps that you need to use
and they would essentially push this
card around the warehouse would pick a
product so it was it made that made it
more compelling for us to use because I
think the battery life the the cost of
the devices all of those factored in as
we looked at these devices and it made
made the process that much more easier
so just to give you a little bit of
history about when these chrome devices
came into play it was not something that
was provisioned by i.t i.t had no
involvement in it it's the operations
and the warehouse operations that were
procuring these devices so we have over
2,500 devices in order for folio and
that those are now now in the past year
as we brought on a chrome enterprise
device management now we're star IT is
now taking over it so that we are
managing the endpoint we are managing
the plugins and so on so it made made a
lot of sense for us to use chrome
devices and we not only use it in the
warehouse but we also when workers
change shifts it just makes that
interaction that much more easier so the
employee experience there is consistent
and then they move from work kissed like
you one location to another location
they don't take the chrome device
them they leave the card there go to the
next place sign out here sign back in
and then they continue the work so and
the add-on value for us was as we looked
at because we are a G suite customer we
have data that we capture through the G
suite application so either in Google
sheets our Google Docs where the workers
that are in the facility picking product
if they if there's some QA issue
whatever they would go on to the toggle
over to the G Google sheets and then
make notes in there so that their
supervisors can interact with it so
they're not only using it for picking
product it also works as a collaborative
device so we've standardized as on the
Chrome browser at stage fix so it's
pretty much everybody that interacts
with our applications both internal or
public cloud applications we are using
Chrome as the standard device as I
shared earlier with the stitch fix
employee population consists of like the
information of knowledge workers or
customer service warehouse associates
and then we have our remote stylists
that are working on their own devices
but they're working remote from that
work from home for as standardizing on a
single browser made a lot of sense and
so we've optimized our applications to
work well with Chrome we are current use
cases for as what we shared earlier is
using Chromebooks for in our warehouse
workers and we are also evaluating pixel
books as an option for our knowledge
worker so interestingly one of our C
level executives who came on board
recently
she-she-she challenged us say like hey
how come you get the provisioning
windows and and and Mac devices why not
chrome devices because she had her own
Chromebook she was used to it in the
past and it just made it made sense for
us to kind of explore that so we are now
exploring pixel book as an option for as
an alternate because everything is in
the cloud and they are not they don't
have a lot compute needs and it that
made it that much more compelling for us
to put that in there so now that is
slowly part of our portfolio and we are
also act currently evaluating about
standardizing on Chromebooks for the
stylus who are currently on a BYOD
because we don't have you know
visibility to that endpoint health and
that's from a security perspective
is a bit challenging so we are exploring
about potentially making a Chrome device
available if the the device that the the
remote stylus has today is not compliant
or that's not up to speed up to date so
there's another extension for so we're
we started with just the the browser the
warehouse workers now looking at other
use cases as well I think one of the
things as I
I know as customer service customer
experience important for the
organization for as employee experience
also is critical because these these
workers are who are interacting on the
Chrome browser especially at the
warehouse we've set up kiosk devices
where people can log in and do deal with
their email or any of the employee
communication so it is also helped us
kind of make that consistent message
across when they're on the shop floor
versus when they are in the office space
when they need to attend to HR or
personal issues and for us it has been I
think that the collaboration capability
is is tremendous it just really helps us
keep up to up-to-date and so far we have
no reported security incidents so that's
actually comforting for us I can sleep
well all right Mike back to you I think
we have plenty of time all right great
thank you thank you very much Robbie
that was super and I think it's always
great to have a customer sort of bring
it to life and as you can tell from
Robbie's experience and a lot of it's a
testament to his leadership is that the
use cases have grown not just within the
front line segment but also the c-suite
and really asking the questions around
why not move to chrome why not move
things more to the cloud just given both
the customer experience as well as the
the IT savings that's associated with
that
[Music]